it's just like everything's nice here
you know I come back from I was in
Brazil or something and you know you see
how you see how good we have it it's
decentralized law enforcement is what
I'm I'm sold in the United States local
cops is the key to Prosperity having a
federal system where they're like they
decide one day that this is illegal now
and everyone in the country the key to
everything is the local yeah I totally
agree and I didn't know that until I
went to Cuba to um Chile and and Peru
and like saw the federal cops on the
corners I'm like we have no idea what
it's like in other countries especially
because we are so used to complaining
about America right everyone's saying
America's so racist and America has all
these cop problems and like travel at
all go anywhere and you'll be happy to
be here